pour ceux qui regardent en replay salut
twitch alors comme toujours au début de
ces stream je vais faire deux trois
petites manips donc si vous regardez en
en replay sur youtube n'hésitez pas à
avancer mais je perds une petite
information à donner c'est que les
tournois être de madère chess comme vont
maintenant être le jeudi soir parce que
comme vous l'avez peut-être vu et
quelques soucis avec les tournants du
vendredi donc on a un peu discuté
le problème c'est qu'il y avait déjà
d'autres arénas en même temps donc ça a
créé un genre de deux d'embouteillage et
road à rennes en même temps donc on a un
petit peu réfléchi et ils se sont dit
qu'on allait mettre du coup ces tournois
c'est arianna francophone le jeudi en
même temps que le stream c'est pas idiot
donc écouter un temps mieux est donc
juste m'ouvrir le le chat pour vérifier
qu'on soit bien bien en ligne que tout
soit bon c'est le cas
donc ouais donc voir cet aréna qui
seront à et donc les jeudis et qui vont
un peu de nous poser problème pour notre
aréna bitstream écouté que faire que
faire que faire on peut pas y faire
grand chose et je vais dû connaître ça
ça et je vais en profiter pour mettre un
message dans le club chaise comme pour
que les gens soient au courant qu'ils on
va laisser les gens un petit peu arriver
ont petit à petit nous ne sommes pas
pressés et c'est très bien ne pas être
pressé
c'est très bien ne pas être pressé
jamais tranquille ans et stream là le
début sous pression directe la personne
qui arrivait donc on est mon nom pas de
message nulle part et on va juste mettre
un petit message dans le club
francophone
ah oui c'est vrai je n'ai pas l'url
parce que j'ai une nouvel ordinateur
donc il va falloir que je récupère à
comment récupérer les clubs
tu vois c'est même moins qu'ils ne sais
plus mais si ça va j'ai trouvé ou pas
c'est pas celui-là 1 mais je participe à
plein de clubs en fait c'est un truc
comme ça s'est fait comme ça c'est fait
ça c'est écrit ok on est bon et ce qu'on
a des gens dans le chatt ouais on a des
saluts on a des yo on a des saluts on a
des idiots bah écoute et salue les mecs
donc donc cette arène francophones qui
débute dans 27 minutes et pour le moins
y'a pas à dire payer personne d'inscrits
dessus donc
inscrivez vous écoute et que dire que
dire que dire
que dire que dire à inscrivez vous
écoutez moi je vais faire une petite
partie le temps que ça arrive un petit
peu le temps que le temps que la
population arrive on va faire un petit
bullet je vais me mettre hop le dit dans
le casque et on va voir ce que ça
donnera faire un petit bullet voir si ça
se passe mieux que que l'enduro marque
lundi c'est pas si mal passé 1 26 26 70
à la fin du tournoi
on a plutôt père fait alors là il va pas
pouvoir prendre des quatre parce qu'il
faut b5 et un échec à la fin il va vous
passez le pli de long va lui placer le
petit f 4 1% en dessin je sais pas si
c'est bon de faire ça d'ailleurs je suis
en train de faire n'importe quoi
parti avec le roi là bas parce que ce
sera mieux
on va chasser le cavale aurait poussé là
le temps de faire des six intermédiaire
ses choix c'est chaud
ok je suis pas je suis pas au taquet
pour du bullet là je sens je le sens
dans lequel était écrit par par là on va
revenir avec la tour on va voir du
cavaliers detroit on n'était pas si mal
au final
je suis un petit peu lent je me sens
laon
je me sens laon soit je me chauffe et
j'essaye de mieux jouer soit soir
attendant voilà on va un peu on va
essayer de se chauffer macha hockey mois
offert 2 3 on va vous laisser arriver
mais je sens que je suis non je sens que
je vois pas bien c'est la vie hein
il ya des jours comme ça et j'ai du mal
à lutter quand je prends je vois pas
bien j'ai du mal à lutter je vois pas
bien l'écran déjà en fait on avait déjà
parlé dans un dans un live je sais plus
comment s'appelle mais j'ai un problème
de vue quand je suis fatigué je sais
plus comment ils appellent ça il y avait
un tonton qui avait dit ça dans le vent
un tonton qu'était olof palme où je sais
plus quoi dans un chat une fois et
j'avais lu sur j'avais vu sur internet
après effectivement tu peux avoir un tat
des gens qui voient moins bien
aïe aïe aïe ça je suis pas penser qu'ils
prendront gecaj aurait fait qu'il prend
g4 tempo mais tu as des gens qui peuvent
avoir un problème de vue avec la fatigue
en fait les yeux qui connecte moins bien
entre eux et c'est ce qui m'arrive
c'est ce qui m'arrive en fait et c'est
assez gênant quand tu dois en bullet
même quand tu joues sur internet en
général parce que tu vois moins bien la
position avant je me prends ça je suis
pas concentré un chantre a raconté
manière même temps bon allez on va on va
surfer mais du coup s et c'est un truc
qui est un peu déstabilisant tu as plus
de mal à garder l'écran dans l'écran
fait mais là n'est imparti était
ridicule alors la machine je suis fait
arrêter pas concentré alors ça je sais
pas trop comment ça tu joues mais c'est
vrai que c'est un peu pénible ce qui
fait je joue mal à l'ouverture je joue
vraiment mal en fait
mais là c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas
des problèmes de vue ou quoi c'est des
problèmes de nullité en fait ce qui est
un problème beaucoup plus grave
c'est un peu le syndrome mitroglou quoi
c'est le syndrome mitroglou c'est
horrible ce que je fais
c'est juste horrible
c'est complètement horrible dominé par
un mec noir fort que moi je déteste ça
mais bon je déteste complètement
ah mince je parie que la dame était
protégé
en hémato prochain bon allez faut qu'on
remonte là mais je m'attendais pas très
bien joué mais pas aussi mal mais
peut-être un peu s'échauffent et surtout
la partie à une partie où j'ai vraiment
mal alors on repart pour ce truc là
mais je comprends pas c'est ça peut pas
être bon en fait ce qu'il a fait
mammeri reprendre la dame mais qu'est-ce
que je suis idiot
j'aime prendre 4 0 contre ce mec là ça
va être moche hein
ça va être chaud alors abandonné directs
auxquels est temps de se reprendre il
est vraiment temps de se replacer la
honte là c'est vraiment la honte je sais
pas trop de temps parce qu'il ya la
reina machin qui va démarrer
c'est mal joué
mais écoutez
je vois aucune tactique c'est la folie
je réfléchis trop longtemps aussi
passent trop de temps à réfléchir
bon allez il est temps de se mettre à
gagner il faut le voir faire tours 2
ce tracé rapide à la souris il joue pas
mal après 1 pour connaître va pas tout
remettre ça sur
sur le dos de la mauvaise forme après on
pourrait 1
ah mince ok enfin une
enfin une victoire a besoin je crois pas
que ce soit mon
parce que du coup on peut se prendre le
car ayant f5 plus tôt ouais c'était pas
terrible
c'était pas fameux
enfin de faire foule 5
c'est pas fameux fameux mais bon
peut-être on s'en sort
quoique les cavaliers des cinq là qui va
arriver à yassa j'avais pas pensé
hi hi hi ha tamm prend g8 mais quelle
horreur moi je fais pas ok mais il peut
prendre prendre et prendra f7 hockey
change de variantes
sont pas là exceptionnel ce qui fait
mais bon pas si mal avec kenny 5 cf
sympa on peut prend on va amener une
tour en d1
on est peut-être bien quand même
on a réussi à glisser plus ou moins mais
je suis lent
pas de chance je vais beaucoup trop
lentement
[Musique]
ça paraît grand chose a refait sa raison
sa non plus d'ailleurs qu'à passer le
front des 5
haye avait des 6 mai au caire
heureusement qu'il est nul en finale
deux pions cavalli avait pas super
étonnant là j'aurais pu le mettre en
ouvre vraiment là de pioncer 1 0 1 en
finale de pury les héros de revenir avec
la sq ont dit ce qu'en dit ça fait
toujours plein
6 quand je pas été très brillant pas
terrible mal gérer l'ouverture sept mois
quand même s'en sortir par quelques
petit subterfuge mai
va se replacer
à
ferais je pas trop trop d'idées
c'est pas mal d'idées c'est toujours un
petit à 4 bien taille mais là je vais
changer ici et je vais faire b5
à
ça c'est pénible chaque sphère damas
huit d'ailleurs
jean repartir menacé d'âme des uns et ça
ça passe allez on revient on revient on
fait quand même parler de l'expérience
fait parler d'eux les vols
genin porte quoi
les pièces super mal placé c'est une
horreur on peut pousser c'est cool qu'il
est rauque et ça nous permet quand même
de renvoyer un peu de jeu parce qu'ils
font honnêtement c'est un peu abusé mais
en bullet ça peut passer en bullet ça
peut passer
on va essayer d'attaquer le pion
c'est en u
[Musique]
fille d'un premier quatre échecs pas de
chance ça va il a rien normalement être
un cahier en d3 et ça va le faire
ok je fais qu'aller sept cavaliers dans
ma chute matt hockey commun comme en
commun
ah c'est pas b4 ici c'est le 5 mai ok ça
a le mérite de le faire réfléchir
quand même prendre la ferté les six
mètres le clan des 5
j'aurais dû mettre l'autre on est dans
la merde on est dans la merde grave et
on n'a pas la moitié d'une idée mise à
part attaqué comme un bourrin mais il
n'y a absolument rien il n'y a pas
d'attaqué rien
c'est un mirage
il n'y a pas le tiers d'une idée
on commence à s'approcher
on est mal autant plus
mais bon mais bon comme un on est
revenue à 5-5 les tontons on est revenu
à 5-5 je sais pas comment est bouddhiste
quand ça veut pas ça veut pas n'est ce
pas parce qu'on est synchronisé 5-0 par
un maître international à deux fous de
francis ou que l'on doit qu'on doit
perdre quoi ça va si on commence par
perdre contre tous les mecs nulle part
contre l'aréna francophones y a personne
qui la joue là les mecs sains trois
joueurs seulement on peut vous inscrire
mais jeudi les problèmes de vue quoi
c'est horrible je vois très mal
l'échiquier ccs affres bastia il fait
mal ça la vrai puisqu'il est vraiment
nul mais mais heureusement qu'il est ce
qu'il est si nul que ça parce que la
position d'été enfin gros je me suis
planté quand je fais le bk trop tôt j'ai
mal times et bombay 4 et du coup la
position après les fins et fayat juste
pas d'attaqué à rien c'est les mecs en
face qui est vraiment nulle heureusement
heureusement mais ça s'est senti prenez
pas les pièces rixe qui s'est
désorganisée tout seul il n'a pas poussé
son pion h parce qu'il a fait pour moi
j'ai rien vu de a à z
j'ai rien vu rien compris mais mais bon
ça a suffi quoi
ça suffit mais rien n'était pas il
n'était pas glorieux là l'adversaire là
c'était pas c'était pas fou fou un conte
est revenue à 5-5 et on s'est pas trop
fait humilier par ce mec s'arrêter
humiliant de perdre s'arrêter qu'un
million de perdre donc heureusement qu'
on est en éviter l'humiliation de
justesse
bon du coup cet aréna francophone on
n'est que trois inscrits je ne sais pas
ce que vous foutez
parce que du coup on fait chasse comme
ils ont changé les horaires de l'aréna
francophones ils l'ont mise le
le jeudi maintenant 20h30
mais ce problème de vue c'est tellement
changé c'est plus ccja de nouveau le mec
au fatalement il peut redire comment
s'appellent ces hyper chiant c'est hyper
sion gens vous assure je suis sûre pour
voir mon écran en fait ouais c'est tous
les jeudis dans vos vies chars ils ont
changé ils ont changé de l'aréna
francophones mais du coup c'est horrible
bref j'ai du mal à voir en fait je peux
voir jouer genre comme ça comme je
regarde quand je tourne les yeux en fait
je vois genre si je fais ça tu vois où
que je ferme les yeux de jeu crime je
vois mais en fait après quand mes yeux
il reste fixé sur l'écran au genre plus
de une ou deux secondes je vois plus
bien ce qui se passe en fait ça fait sa
une migraine ophtalmique je crois pas
que c'était ça le nom mais en tout cas
c'est affreux ça ne fait pas mal à la
tête ou quoi mais ça ne le fait pas que
sur l'écran ça me le fait enfin je
regarde n'importe quoi ça me le fait et
je peux mettre les lunettes d'écran je
peux mettre ce que je veux ça change
plus rien après c'est fini en fait quand
c'est comme ça c'est fini mais c'était
panique à naftal nick est un mec qui m'a
mis en mots l'autre jour j'ai regardé
sur wikipédia c'était tout à fait ça
et c'est hyper désagréable mais j'ai lu
qu'ils avaient beaucoup de gens qui
avaient le même problème donc je suis
pas le seul dans ce cas là mais c'est
vraiment hyper chiant avec 10 pts mais
j'ai fait une sieste en fait j'ai fait
une sieste mais je sais pas tu fais une
si la soirée que je re dorment peut-être
mais je veux plus vous dire le mot c'est
un mois un peu scientifique quoi c'est
un mot un peu scientifique mais en gros
tu as des gens pour pour simplifier en
fait pour simplifier ce qui avait écrit
dans l'article wikipédia pour simplifier
en gros il est expliqué que tu as des
personnes donc moi tu as des des abrutis
quoi en gros quand ça gagne un certain
stade de fatigue je sais pas trop parce
que c'est pas forcément de la fatigue
physiquement route un truc de fatigue
est en fait atteint un certain stade et
le truc c'est que tes yeux du coup ils
tiennent complètement con donc adele ne
comprennent plus rien ils viennent
vraiment débile et il se met à mal koné
capa a plus regardée au même endroit
ensemble c'est un peu eux ils sont là
ils sont fous tu vois d'habitude ils
sont là ils travaillent ils marchent de
concerts j'ai envie de venir tu as cfc
un voire deux flûtes et un pianiste quoi
donc ils sont là avant tu as le joueur
de flûte bon lui non ça ne m'intéresse
plus en fait il t'as l'impression de jeu
par astérix obélix à l'abruti qui joue
de la harpe sais où je sais plus comment
s'appelle à son instrument c'est lui en
fait les mecs ils ne jouent plus de
concerts quoi et du cou et du coup tu en
sueur total étaient en sueur total et tu
vois plus très bien justement à cause de
ça en fait 1 go de mémoire c'est ça
l'histoire des tout à un high kick est
plus con que l'autre
bon
bon j'espère que vous avez bien compris
ce que j ai enfin ne me croyez pas
n'allez pas voir le médecin en lui
disant oui j'ai entendu sur internet
mais très intéressant un crime très
intéressant qui a dit ça et tout et tu
dis oui mais donc non non non c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas du tout scientifique
ans à un mec qui a écrit ça qui
apparemment était ophtalmo nom des gens
ne s'est pas un saint mais sur un chat
which moi qui apparemment ne rappelle un
article wikipédia que j'ai lu à six mois
et qui leur dit dans dans le string donc
si tu veux en gros ça n'a aucune valeur
ce que je viens de dire tu viens de
perdre du temps quoi en gros mais aussi
bref que vous je prêt à c'est un peu le
même système mais ça se voit pas
vraiment si tu me vois si tu me regardes
tu vas pas voir que les yeux et tu vois
il déconnecte un tout petit peu c'est
très léger ouais c'est ça c'est un mec
de doctissimo
le mec a lu un article donc
automatiquement bon ben il est il était
à migrer des ophtalmos monsieur ça lui a
fait l'homme qu'elle aime d'ophtalmo
mois quelque part si tu en ayant lu un
article wikipédia j'ai envie de tenir
gmac plus j'ai bac + 8 en médecine si je
suis là et derrière tu vois je te redit
sa population mais on ne sait pas
combien on aime on est 100 médecins en
gros les 100 médecins là si vous voulez
donc on est là bon vin est ce qu'il ya
des diagnostics à faire tu vois que
comme comment ça se passe en gros sans
risque sans vraiment tenir utilisant un
strabisme divergent mais il avait un
terme dogues ph
il avait vraiment un terme et je te jure
j'ai dû chercher le truc sur youtube
c'est exactement ça mais oui c'est dans
cet esprit là on triture vient nous dire
bonjour ou pas n'ont ils pas bonjour
enfin gères tu fais ce que tu veux
donc attendons n'est que 5 dans le
tournoi qu'est ce que c'est que ça pour
qu'on n'est que 5 pourquoi convient
qu'on bienvenue sur ce live on est on
est deux on est quoi on est on est
quatre il sait pas chaud ils sont 2,4
annoncés tu te fous de ma gueule mais on
n'est pas quatre mais j'en sais mais
peut-être on est 4 mai même si on écarte
quand bien même on serait 4 et alors
j'ai fait du stream et on s'en fou qu'on
soit 4 ou 1000
qu'est ce que ça change il ya les
tontons qui sont lassés des tontons
c'est impressionnant
c'est impressionnant c'est
impressionnant
tu te fous de ma gueule impressionnante
mais je sais pas combien d'années je ne
vais pas regarder je sais pas on n'est
pas sur la chaîne distri moi aussi sur
la chaîne tci ce point comme tu vois ça
peut jouer mais j'ai pas sur le ton ils
sont que 7 je sais pas ce qu'ils foutent
il y en a je ne sais pas ce qu'ils
foutent
du coup on va sur une partie des gens à
regarder ce qu'ils font allez moi je
vais m'inscrire les cheveux contrainte
on tient à l'esam show fait mal et moi
je suis dans le tournoi quoi ça les
motive à venir après je me barre dès que
dès qu'ils arrivent ne pas jouer contre
moi très attention ne sais même pas ce
que j'ai en plus on est 80 ni cela m'a
donc c'était pas la peine de se [ __ ]
de ma gueule
attention quand même mais on n'est pas
beaucoup sur la chaîne chaise comme
quand on fait des trucs du jeudi parce
que les gens vont venir demain soir pour
le pour l'aréna et moi j'attends d'être
à paris et la fougue il m'apparaît pas
qu'on triche est dans sa phase iia ajout
contredit pas alors qu'il pensait faire
une terre locale et à l'egypte a chauffé
toi dis pas qui est membre de diamants
d'ailleurs donc automatiquement sa place
au dessus de tout le monde mais moi
aussi je suis monde pourquoi moi j'ai
pas mon diamants il est où le diamant
moi je faisais du diamant à temps mais
je suis encore maman diamant comme mais
je suis plus membre de diamants qu'est
ce que c'est que cette merde battant
mais comment je vis si je suis mon
diamant pourquoi je suis plus
mondialement dressa un scandale mais je
suis très énervé et comment je vais
faire mais tactiquement le matin là à
temps mais c'est quoi ce scandale du
tout est écrit ratchet point com
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça se foutent de
ma gueule chaise comme incroyable ça
puisqu'il est saisie se passe
c'est une honte mais attends je vais
leur écrire immédiatement - ça ça va pas
se passer comme ça là on m'enlève pas
mon membres diamant comme ça moi je vous
dis tout de suite ça c'est pas des
choses qui sont qui sont possibles quand
on joue la petite structure compte lui
aussi dans le système de londres à le
faire le thé et c'est michael bay 6 qui
arrivait à 4 mais c'est quand même le
cadet de nos soucis fumantes diamants
non mais attends jamais vu ça incroyable
incroyable
y'a plus de respect il joue pas mal là
en faisant son petit truc de cavaliers
tous assez bien joué c'est exactement ce
qu'il fallait faire j'aurais dû jouer
plus tôt et je voulais voir s'il allait
faire cavaler h4 pour me prendre le fou
je voulais lui laisser une chance pour
écouter je joue pas je joue pas au top
pour le moment mais c'est plus ou moins
volontaire donc il a bien joué il prend
mon fou et du coup ça va lui permettre
de regagner le contrôle de la casse bien
alors là il prend des risques quand même
parce que d'un côté il m'a enfermée mon
fou en jambes et 4 mais mon fou il va
ressortir c'est pacman là si tu veux
c'est pac man 2 enfin je perds quelques
parpaings en espagne 3 détient donc il
doit déjà avoir un pac man 3d ok j'ai
encore mes diamants heureusement
heureusement comment vivre sans le
membre diamant j'ai pas comment vous
faites dans le chat si vous n'êtes pas
en diamant des ils m'attaquent dessin
convaincra t on va protéger
heureusement je suis encore encore
diamant attend donc là le fou j'ai même
pas envie de prendre sa tour j'ai envie
de ça j'ai envie de lui raser tous ses
pions je rase les pions déjà déjà pris
deux dû raser deux pions déjà
à partir pas forcément fameux fameux ce
qu'on a fait prendre la toile était
peut-être plus simple et mon envie de
garder pacman pacman pas connaître c'est
quoi cette chanson ridicule là c'était
c'était c'était william leymergie nom
qui chanter cette chanson n'est pas un
truc comme ça et ça c'est pas que matt
pac man et il y avait un truc comme ça
mais c'est bien william leymergie que
chanter ça ou pas bon alors on prend là
du coup ci prend du cavaillon va
finalement prendre la call of si
production va faire h sicile par ici on
va faire g5y par ici on va faire des 4
ha ok bien là à bas coût du kwh par an
ces huit avec le droit mais c'est pas
encore si simple simple pas une grande
partie a une nouvelle fois c'était un
tour c'est cette ré s'est pas fait et
fait encore basses qui confirme ce que
william leymergie qu'il a été là quand
même on a pas mal de menaces là on
maintient sa summa sous attaque on a sa
source menace
on va prendre du fou au moins on va
empêcher à la tour de de participer et
notre plan il est simple un c est quelqu
un les paroles de cette chanson de
pac-man là où il ya que moi qui la
connaît est ce qu'on peut nous lâcher
cette info ah oui alors sur le tchat sur
le chat j'ai envie de dire sur une
chaise vide stream nous qu'on nous lâche
les paroles on nous écrit sur l'autre
chat rond comme un ballon et plus jaune
qu'un citron c'est lui pacman pacma
gentil petit bonhomme poursuit par les
fantômes c'est lui pacman pac man tu as
caché je chante super mal quoi mais bon
je connais pas trop le rythme et se
laissait pas les paroles d' avance
minime
voilà on est quand même très bien aller
on enchaîne
est-ce que ça chauffe séjournant ça
chauffe pas spécialement les gens pour
venir jouer d'ailleurs les gens se
foutent complètement du tournoi le
génial
pas de chance grave à tort allez une
robe
il est venu pour s'aggrave à tort dayan
sûr il peut déjà abandonné je pense à
bim
il joue comme magnus
nîmes
protéger notre pions 1
pac man
alors cette petite position oui c'est
tout ça à troyes b 4-1 ça ressemble un
petit peu à benoni à l'envers on va
s'organiser
je passe sur à y arriver c'est une
position pour rire mais on joue une
grave hein donc j'ai envie de dire on
est au courant
alors on va peut-être un écailler par là
on va avoir évidemment on se met en
difficulté d'entrée est ce que le mot
c'était nystagmus off
je ne sais pas je peux pas te dire mais
je pense pas à demain
[Musique]
on s'organise avec nos pièces fait ce
qu'on peut
le prochain du froid et norris
bon je bouge mais pièce un peu n'importe
comment pour le vent j'attends je laisse
venir
on est là pour se marrer je veux pas
forcément accablé mon adversaire allait
changer et faire une super partie je
vais laisser sa chance et puis ici de
l'arnaqué à la fin et puis s'ils gagnent
ils gagnent 6 gravatar gagne ça lui fera
un beau souvenir marocain mais c'est de
l'empêcher nécessaire quand même lui
laisser le souvenir amer d'une défaite
alors il est en train de recueillir mon
sens qui perd du terrain
allez
il peut prendre en d5 aussi j'avais pas
vu je vais prendre des cinq ans je suis
une mauvaise partie mais bon c'était une
grave et puis on parle de tout et de
rien non c'est pas un stream pédagogique
donc on peut se permettre de réussir à
faire une jolie forme géométrique en
faisant f e
ce qui donnera une structure un peu
marrante
donc ils auraient dû faire dame des sept
épreuves 5 1 voilà partis pour bon c'est
pas c'est pas joli joli mais on va se
retrouver peut-être dans un truc marrant
possible construisons une pulsion
marrant parce que là cette position là
c'est fantastique on va faire h5 et je
vais essayer d'amener le ranger 4 les
mecs allez je suis chaud je mets le
ranger 4 allée ça est quand même
fantastique gore l'orangé 4 franchement
sa salle mettant sur jeu mon temps j'ai
quatre mois je monte à la volée j'ai le
roi akif il est hyper chaud il va
protéger les pieux être superbe et
angers 4 la chanson est mon adversaire
complètement sur les mains et il s'y
attendait pas du tout l'iphone est fou
que se passe-t-il quoi le roi pourrait
donc il monte à la volée enfin fou du
roi très bien protégé angers iv un roi
de la grotte
j'ai envie de te dire il s'est mis sur
la case de la grotte et maintenant on va
se décaler magnifique
parce pente astic c'est dommage que je
suis pas leur gré des quand même est
monté jusqu'en jusqu'en g6 alors
maintenant on va se décaler comme ça on
va regarder dans trois là bas il est
très beau mais peut-être on se fait un
délire on peut pas j'ai envie de me
faire un délire ça de faire une course
de rois et de partir de partout avec le
roi et après de jouer mais j'allais
vraiment allait réussir à faire du roi
g6 un jour dans cette partie quand même
c'est un objectif
ça reste un objectif on va les triplés
marc à faire 3 à 5 ans en famille
ça m'a l'air pas mal tour des 5
on peut ramener laurent le cadre du coup
obligé de bouger la dame ou pas allez on
fait dams et 5 mai dans l'esprit et on
revient à faire rouaroua leucate c'est
quand même super dans l'esprit de faire
ça on a nos deux pions pas assez et qui
sont très bien on fait trois ou quatre
tours j'ai un fourbe et quatre jeux
colmate la tour peut pas bouger le fou
et en sueur corps j'ai un talent sûr là
le niveau dessus arrêt assez important
pour gravatar
car à tort qu'ils en sueur
les pions pouces
bon on a réussi à gagner
c'était joli un master est inesthétique
mans génialement j'irais pas jusqu'a
génial mais c'était bowdam c5 c'est
sympa allez on refait une carreaux
cannes ça nous a pas mal réussi lacarrau
cannes tout à l'heure et on va jouer la
vente avec ef
ok je faisais prendre des quatre sets ça
existe après je suis pas
faut que je fasse gaffe peut-être pas
fait rage ce système peut y avoir du
danger la menace d'être cavaliers 5 mai
qui lui sont faits d'armes à cinq échecs
je crois encore en tête ça existait un
fou des trois aujourd'hui faire cavalier
provokat est juste égaliser direct bref
cet amas cinq échecs pose la question
marche ça marche et n'a enfin je veux
dire j'attaque jatta quand même son
voyage au tac son cavalier enfin gérard
françois et mc5 je l'avais vu mais je ne
l'aurais pas jouer tu n'es pas assez
dans l'esprit thirion thirion j'ai envie
de dire en sueur
mesdames c'est simple c'était sympa à
taille mais bon c'est la différence
entre streamer etc ou plus qui jouent
des ventes des changes de l'asl avait
dit streamer - eco plus quoi qui te
donne des dames en a enfin aller on tue
pour la beauté des échecs quoi fin tu as
tu sais que tu es un peu romantique tu
vois j'ai envie de dire tu veux tu fais
du bon quoi c'est pas là que pour gagner
c'est là pour gagner mais avec l'esprit
avec la beauté du jeu ouais c'est un peu
plus intéressant quand même voiture y on
sait pas trop ce qui ferait la gamme une
caisse de moi j'adhère faire des
exercices d'échec joue dans l'esprit des
trucs et rhume genre faites vous la main
machin tu as un truc qui ne servent à
rien et ce serait pas mal de faire une
série d'exercices joué dans l'esprit ça
aurais tu as trouvé un coût qui va qui
gagne mais enfin qu'est aussi dans
l'esprit quoi et tu feras des pièges du
foie de juste donner une dame en impasse
que voilà tu es dans l'esprit thiérion
qui rend sur thirion alors un bacchus à
abacus allée bacchus on lui fait f4
alors ce qui nous donne le petit bacchus
on va voir ce qui donne le petit bacchus
comment va-t-il jouer
c'est pas un et ce qu'ils en sueur déjà
le rôle christian n'était qu'un arrêt
bien dit
voir ce que fait bacchus un échec a déjà
bien lui faire un truc dans l'esprit un
sacrifice de dames ou quoi mais ça
fonctionne pas et on va faire des 4
apprendre de la dame a vraiment fait un
peu n'importe quoi l'on va se redresser
plus tard c'est un peu l'idée qu on
démarre avec une position un peu bizarre
on va essayer de créer de l'harmonie
plus tard on laisse la main à bacchus en
espérant que nous servent une bonne une
bonne bouteille de rouge à la sortie
prendre son cahier pour une joue pas mal
bacchus un effet sa partie il fait sa
partie on va quand même on va quand même
un peu le le mettre sous pression le
bacchus bien joué un grand rôle qu'ils
ont à lui faire j'ai quatre on va voir
ce qu'il donne le petit bacchus on va
lui faire peur on va faire peur à
bacchus va faire trembler bacchus
maintenant bacchus malin bacchus ils
échangent les dames
malin comme un singe d'activa cus
intéressant écoutez pour le moment on
réussit pas à le n'a pas réussi à le
elles mettront sueur bacchus va
continuer à essayer un
mais pas très bien du coup on fait un
peu n'importe quoi au début on n'a plus
aucune harmonie on a plus de case
blanche hermine qui pour protéger son
pouce pas mal joué ok mon bail et
changer ça mais c'est vrai que c'est un
peu pénible à cette case 4 on continue
d'essayer de faire peur je passe il a
vraiment peur mais bon on est c'est quoi
mais si l'attaqué droit de bacchus
malgré le déficit et si fait cavalier ou
quatre cavaliers f de lonval eux on va
lui laisser la qualité écoutez c'est
d'attaquer son roi sans dame
allez on y va à fond on va essayer de
mener une attaque de maths sans dame
passe à bacchus 5 le carillon d'écarter
part à la nuit on va on va on va lui
faire cadeau
écoutez moi je dis s'il veut prendre la
calloc'h qu'ils aillent nous on va on
pousse à fond quoi on pousse à fond et
là j'ai l'impression qu'on est en train
de mener une petite attaque parce qu'on
a le fou qui peut se réveiller menacé
m'attends à schwyz bacchus qui est
peut-être un peu en danger la tension
bacchus
moi j'y fais gaffe parce qu'on est quand
même qu'il ait prononcé six tours à la
fuite matin
alors écoutez on a plein de choix mais
on va continuer à ne jouer que pour
mater en fait on va continuer dans cet
esprit décès de maths et bacchus service
volée on ne va pas faire un coup de
défense
bacchus qui se bat bien mais vaincu ce
qui est sous pression un an je pense pas
qu'il soit très bien enfin un petit coup
de tours à fiat aurait pu faire qui les
prend aussi s'armer tourache c'est très
fort parce que du coup si monde il fait
mater en un don qui redescend et
maintenant à parquet prend aussi son run
asmat angers7
et surtout rêve c'est ton frère à tour a
chuté il sera enfermé il sera matos i
way bacchus qui s'est pas mal battu mais
çe pas notre attaque était pas si
violente que ça c'est peut-être h61 et
nous il nous a laissé lui ouvrir la
colonne hfr jouer le fou tessier juste
fait cavalier de 4 à la rigueur je pense
pas qu'ils aient eu grand-chose à
l'attaqué était pas folichonne
folichonne mais en faisant h6 en fait
nous a way en faisant office en fait il
nous a un peu permis d'ouvrir sa colonne
à une fois que la colonne a été ouverte
là c'était la chante la totale pour
bacchus donc partie intéressante bacchus
qui a bien joué mais kamal gérer la
défense de son roi allez on joue conte
cyril 85
elle fait très attention je parle belge
ou suisse
je suis suisse romande fait très
attention sur elle beaucoup de langues
je parle québécois aussi même que tu te
mets qui met donc partie intéressante
face à bacchus
c'était très intéressant cette partie
contre bacchus
bacchus qui a coupé le son mais elle
était pas mal la partie bacchus tu
pourra la voir en rediffusion ça peut
être intéressant pour toi c'était une
bonne partie tu t'es fait un peu
impressionné par mon attaque où je sais
pas tu as pas trop géré en fait en
touchant au pion à 6 ce qui se passe on
lâche 6 et que tu m'as laissé ouvrir les
colonnes après c'était dangereux
voilà vous compte cyril donc on a une
structure de type carlsbad comme un
gambit dame à l'envers refusé et on va
essayer de placer une attaque de
minorités donc on va faire un petit rat
qu on a réglé le problème du foot case
blanche donc ça c'est une bonne nouvelle
on va parler colère un petit b4 la
taille de minorités et cyril cyril qui
doit s est joué pour la case de 5,1
j'imagine cyril série qui doit être au
taquet là encore on peut l'expliquer
c'est peut-être pas idéal j'essaye juste
de jouer comme ça un peu à l'arraché
je fais un peu ma vie un paria peut-être
c4 mais mon inscription isolé cette dame
b si c'était pas très pas fou non mais
c'est quand je vais prendre faire damas
six et puis je jouerai lp on est isolé à
isola tad absolument rien dire on va lui
coller une tour enseigne ici a pas de
calais 17 je veille au grain et on
menace dame prend des quatre ans déjà je
vous aime bien menacé
bon on va faire un tabac à 5 comme ça on
va menacer peut-être le pion à dehors
jusqu'à quel point ce pion à dos
d'ailleurs champions prend bk un tour
prend ses deux pions prend à 5 tours
prend des deux c'est quand même
important de le souligner l'espagne
souligne art très important et on peut
peut-être faire puis on prend qui on
prend fois à troyes avoir sorti alors
écoutez on va prendre une fois on va
prendre deux fois
et on apprend ici pourquoi la pollution
n'était pas à spartoo.com j'ai joué
j'avais fou b4 d'ailleurs les fruits
qu'à trouver 4 ça gagner sur le champ
sera concentrée d'un temps pas à
concentrer mais inquiétant pour pour la
red hat demain j'espère que je jouerai
mieux mais bon
am ont appris les pions
mais bon quand tu manques un peu
d'adversité c'est toujours difficile de
rester concentré
alors allez je pense que je comprends
son idée on va faire dame 17
je pense qu'il veut faire d'un f4 et du
coup on aurait dame prend 17
bon du coup on va faire un exercice dans
ce cas précis on va attaquer car et ie 5
qui est le cavalier qui protège le
cavalier 17 et là ça doit aller on a le
kapsys qui défend le pion tout tout
semble défendu la cyril cyril 85 en
sueur n'a pas vraiment grand monde 1 sur
ce tournoi franchement les tontons only
super le match du 4 km qui cache agité
sur la moitié du jeu alors de calmer ça
je suis par le tonton je vois pas de
message personnellement à on joue contre
et anne à l'état ne va lui faire une
robe risque est sûre la groupe contre
étals mais bon bah on va on va tenter et
anne qui veulent pousser quatre
vainqueurs méthane capossela grob ou pas
d'ailleurs
va-t-il se faire grauby fier
on va voir ce qu'est tan nou joue sur la
grotte parce que mon la grotte comme une
ouverture très respectable et très
respectée bien évidemment tout le monde
respecte la grande virée fish l'a pas
poussé la grave or comment est-ce que tu
peux aujourd'hui vouloir prétendre à
quelque chose aux échecs sans rabot
c'est la grotte je veux dire ah bon
c'est la grotte ça reste quand même très
très important quoi moi j'ai toujours
aux jeunes bosser là grob
c'est vraiment mon conseil aux nouvelles
générations quoi une fois qu une fois
que tu as bossé la grotte et bien quoi
rien pour le tournoi c'est ici mais il
faut être inscrit sur le club ché scop
fr vraiment important de bosser
s'aggrave alors
alors alors du coup il me prend là je
reprends et je vais pouvoir jouer un peu
contre ses pions donc et hannecart a
quand même réussi l'exploit d'être moins
bien dans une robe
il va faire fou pranger savent affaire
cassé cet tchac tchac tchac tout est
attaqué la grotte a encore frappé et
thann ccpt grauby fier pas de chance
lâche en khl il s'est fait grauby fier
maintenant on va essayer d'échanger une
paire de tours si on peut
aïe aïe aïe grauby fier et anne grauby
fier et allez on va continuer à grauby
c'est tout le monde je les prends le set
gagné eux
ouais possible
j'arrivais qu'à l'étranger 5 dirait
qu'il n'avait pas un truc emprise
je me rappelle plus
faut juste de protéger et a carrément
parce que je suis nul je la regardais ça
facilement wec et prend le chemin gagner
ici marrant ça
fatigue visuelle donnant l'aspect de la
fatigue visuelle c'est c'est kaka kaka
visuelle par une fatigue visuelle c'est
tout à l'heure là c'est juste pas de
concentration pas de pas de forme mais
c'est dur de jouer contre des joueurs
plus faibles comme sa répétition
c'est dur de maintenir son niveau en
fait quand tu fais ça parce que tu te tu
vois dans les arénas quand j'étais moins
en forme quand j'étais plus fatigué je
veux des meilleures parties contre les
joueurs force que gentil plus facilement
leurs coûts du coup ça donne des parcs
plus facile à jouer enfin plus facile je
veux contre un joueur plus faible
normalement mais dans le cas où tu es un
peu crevé août a du mal à voir c'est
plus facile que contre un mec fort savez
pas lire tu auras des meilleurs
résultats mais genre tu vas faire moins
de gaffe on dirait du scandinave mais
c'est une
c'est une grosse mine avant fait c'est
ce qu'on appelle une groupie nav
françois jacq moitié grob moitié
scandinave grauby nav ouverture très
intéressante bien évidemment c'est la
base des échecs et donc moi je vais
jusqu'à 21h30 normalement et j'ai fait
un petit pari avec chaises comme jordi
j'avais gagné le tournoi mais j'ai
l'impression que ça va pas être possible
thomson je vais perdre mon pari avec
chaises comme parce que j'ai bête il ya
autant de points que moi et leur effet
que le toit soit un peu plus fort
tournant et pas assez relevé ou alors
que je joue contre les premiers s'en
aille
mais bon on aura fait des groupes dont
quelque part le pari sera gagné on est
peut-être les seuls à avoir fait des
groupes dans ce tournoi j'ai passé eu
d'autres gros beast mai
mais j'ai pas l'impression qu'il eut
d'autres rabbins en tout cas dites moi
c'est lui dites moi dans le chat si vous
avez vu d'autres groupes dans ce tournoi
comment on fait pour et contre moi il
faut jouer le tournoi
alors maintenant allez on va pousser les
pions
trêve de plaisanterie fini de jouer fini
de rire les tontons la commedia signe de
rire les tontons m'attend c'est cette
allée à on joue contre bath alors on
fait quoi
contrebasse on va être obligé d'être un
peu piquant contrebasson objet d'être un
peu piquant écoutez on lui fait une
grande avec les noirs on va gober bosse
avec les noirs bosse en sueur total face
à la grogne trachée pas s'il écoute
je tente
je regarde pas l'écran je veux pas voir
sa basse gosse qui a raté le match en 1
à bosses comment tu as raté sa tonton à
tomber
oh la la la la la cata la cata de tonton
gauche rat je voulais pas voir ça
j'avais peur de me le prendre à tonton
buzz aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe tonton oh
là là mais c'est pas fini encore un cas
on est passé pas très loin de la
correctionnelle à en l'attenté à on
l'attend et celle là c'était chaud on
n'est pas passé loin de se faire mater
par bus aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe je les
risques et je les risques et je les
risques et s'arrêter contre quelqu'un
d'autre qui l'aurait vu il était
tellement pas loin de la sphère
j'ai pas si j'espérais qu'il le voit ou
pas en fait je sais pas si j'espérais
qu'il le voit ou pas d'un côté j'avais
envie qu'il me bat savoir et fait marrer
d'un autre côté je n'avais pas du tout
envie de perdre je sais pas si j'en
avais envie ou pas en tout cas c'était
marrant
mais bon les mecs
c'est l'esprit aussi les cd m'attendais
enfin c'est russie l'esprit mais je
pense que s'ils n'écoutent pas le stream
il va nous dire qu'il a fait une belle
partie après il va étant sûr quand il va
savoir que qu'il avait en m'attendant à
c'était sympa tachin elle aurait pu la
gagner il aurait pu la gagner mais
maintenant plus de cadeaux maintenant on
va essayer de de serrer la vis mais
stephen
est ce que tu as vu parce que tu as
atteint m'attendant ou pas
allez basse qui échoue encore tout est
encore possible il a encore un pion plus
tout peut arriver
majid il encore pas mal
il a encore bien buzz on paye encore un
peu notre notre connerie mais on remonte
petit à petit graduellement on revient
dans la game
après ce qu'on va réussir à est ce qu'on
va réussir à remonter complètement sait
moins c'est loin d'être sûr c'était cool
quand même induit décès le matin
safra l'ipad u stream
on va essayer d'aller le vice et la
barre elle a maintenant plus de blagues
un boss plus de blagues on ne joue plus
écoutons walesa allait prendre le pion
va aller s'occuper en valais raser ce
cas de ce côté-là raser les deux pions
on a réussi à lui raser les deux pions
alors en train de lui faire mal
on lui a fait très mal
bim bim tous les pions qui tombe ya f3
qui arrive en plus alors l'espace 2 en
l'espace de quelques coups glace a tout
perdu
aïe aïe aïe ah ouais mais bon après j'ai
serré le jeu un tout d'un coup
on a eu chaud
on a eu chaud on n'est pas passé loin de
la correctionnelle face au loin de la
correctionnelle
je suis la gagner mais c'est passé
tagne qu'on aura perdu dans l'esprit
allez on retente notre truc c'est être à
jouer en basse sûr c'est que tu le
verras c'est dans l'esprit de tous les
mêmes attendre
ou alors est ce qui nous connaît ce qui
sait nous réfuté le convaincre on
appelle ça déjà le machin le gambit je
me rappelle même plus du nom tellement
c'est pourri mais c'était fun et je
pensais que tu verrais honnêtement je
pensais que tu verrais mais je pense que
tu l'aurais il aurait vu contre
quelqu'un d'autre en fait je pense que
buzz silva aurait vu contre quelqu'un
d'autre je pense était le fait que ce
soit moi qui joue il s'est dit qu'il
pouvait pas y avoir de m'attendre il n'a
pas regardé
c'est l'impact de psychologie du nom
quoi et du coup
du coup c'est pas ça alors je trouve qu
elle s'appelle couleurs ados gambie de
ce truc c'est complètement fou rire à et
bim
bon vous savez que là quand je fais ces
arénas j'en vois je fais n'importe quoi
je suis importe quoi je laisse un peu de
je vous laisse un peu de possibilités
j'en vois un peu n'importe comment ça
vous demeurez futé
saha vous demeurez futé voit là par
contre maintenant le four à th 5
il est pas très beau et du coup ils
tombent tweak tout ce lot il ya tout qui
tombe pour tous et tous l'ont vraiment
je sais pas si les gens sont pas vues
sur le toit ce qu'ils savaient pas
comment s'inscrit aussi parce qu'ils
veulent ils veulent me voir faire le con
mais en tout cas c'est dommage qu'on
n'ait pas été plus nombreux
tu peux m'attendre mais tu peux venir
sur le stream est à cinq minutes un jeu
pas tu n'es pas t'es pas très stream
on a remarqué ça avec les tontons pire
moment t'es pas très strict
tu te sens pas streams nom d'orange et
cet échec je suis tout reproche cet
échec
on a laissé notre adversaire revenir
dans la partie et coûté tant mieux hein
ça pimente un peu l'histoire il ya le
fou qui va tomber ça va être chaud
pourquoi qu'on va faire tous réfutent
peut-être en fait à lyon après move
allez on est gourmand auprès move to
réfutons menasra tour f1
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe le prévenu de la
mort il y avait tout ranger 5 et c'est
pour ça que j'avais près move
alalalala too big too slow qui en
donnant une pièce en un nous met en
grand danger
ilisu lys où aller on that avec une dame
de moins écoutés on a pris le risque de
près move
allez on sait pas attendu à fouler 5 qui
perdent une pièce sur le chant c'était
bien joué c'était dans l'esprit il est
récompensé il est récompensé et c'est
tant mieux
ils méritent ils méritent ils méritent
ils méritent d'être récompensés ce coup
j'ai cinq était quand même plus dans
l'esprit que les autres coûts et ça fait
plaisir que ça lui a permis de gagner
quelque chose
allez on fait roi des six on monte à
fond
est-ce qu'on peut encore s'inscrire oui
bien sûr allez on va revenir avec le
cavalier on va aller faire l'effort d'en
revenir vers f40 on va taper on va taper
g2 malgré la dame de moi on n'a qu'à ma
ronde et 6 très bien placé au rang des
cistes et superbement placé plein centre
plein fer ils protègent les pions
centraux donc ça on sent quand même que
c'est une bonne pièce son cavalier à
trois qui a la rue et là il ya le quart
eli qui va jaillir en f4 à ça va faire
mal
ça va faire mal et on peut même menacer
du tour pranger deux cavaliers quatre
épreuves de allez on est on est puissant
touitou selon en sueur et bien écoutez
bim le pion le pion et cloud et du coup
maintenant bassin tombe à s'en prendre à
f3 bîmes des rois aussi tranquille leroy
impérial on a des plus forts roi du
monde
plus rien ne peut nous arriver on va
prendre on va prendre un f3 on va faire
elle va réfléchir une seconde si on fait
by me fais bim et voilà c'est de faire
bîmes on peut faire un échec qui on
revient à f 7 et on couvre toutes les
cases d'entrée de la dame fantastique
trois grands tours f7
on contrôle la colonne des serres que
cette colonne est quasiment à nous ah
c'est beau les échecs nous fait un petit
échec
on revient
on contrôle toutes les cases
on contrôle toutes les cases malgré la
dame
alors j'ai bel allez on va refaire une
robe
on va refaire une grand palais est ce
que je fais selon la dame non non pas du
tout
je congèle est deuxième de ce tournoi
est donc partie très difficile là
surtout que joue pas mal moi qui m'a
déjà battu et c'est vrai que la drogue
c'est pas pas l'assurance tout risque 1
j'ai pas quand est-ce que je pouvais
prendre là là on fait du goût
ce que j'ai pas du tout vu en fait
alors qu'est ce que ça donne cette grob
côté c'est peut-être pas si mal mais il
faut être abonné pour le tournoi non pas
du tout
la gagne et sa folie il faut lui casser
son c'est clément il aura une heure
après pour me rendre au caire on se
barre
on se barre et on va essayer avec ses 5
et food et si c'est parce que c'est
marrant
parce que c'est amusant de jouer pour
l'espace à fond comme ça devenir parent
on va venir casser ça ici et c'est prêt
move un peu
mais senna un peu près move
nesirky f5 là qui on prendra ici
un jour un peu sérieux en prenant 17 on
va être un poil sérieux précise prison
le jouer avec tous rêvent 7 après
éventuellement
on verra bien en tout cas on joue vite
comment rejoint le tournant alors faut
fois les suffrages faut être sur le sur
le club ché ce com fr peut-être
quelqu'un peux te mettre le lien dans le
chat alors d'amener cette on a envie de
jouer dans l'esprit évidemment
je veux dans l'esprit c'est jouer
connement fait mais par le seul coup
dans l'esprit c'est ça à écouter c'est
très mauvais
on fait l'esprit à fond les mecs quitte
à perdre en prend quand même si on fait
tout reprendre et 5 c'est l'esprit à
fond allez on est dans l'esprit à fond
tant pis tant pis on a une tour on a
quoi de moins on a deux noms on a une
qualité une tour de moins ok bon mais on
a des pions
ça
je vous le dis tout de suite ça va pas
être évident pousser les pions déjà à
fond on va pousser ce qu'on peut et
après on verra ça c'est pas mal on a
récupéré déjà une pièce et on garde nos
fous est ce que l'esprit est en train de
vaincre
du coup on veut monter le roi maintenant
paris l'a abandonné à l'esprit était
trop fort pour gbl était sympa cette
partie quand même bec avec les quatre
pions centraux qui avance peu à fond
enfin je sais pas si ça vous a plu
moi je fais ça pour faire marrer les
mecs
alors on fait une dernière à les mines
dernière une der des der
ce faisant la grève est reconduite mais
aussi un mais c'est sympa l'esprit à
fond les pions au centre on pousse
c'était beau quelque part non après je
sais pas à quel point ça vous fait
kiffer un mois ça me fait marrer parce
que je suis parce que ça me fait rire en
fait mais je sais pas vous savez à quel
point ces hauts faits maria vient mettre
l'adresse du club
mais c'est sympa comme concept de jouer
avec les quatre pions et capture
ensemble pour pousser allez on finit
contre le rige essaie de finir en france
on va essayer de finir en force pour
marquer des points mais je pense que
j'ai bête va finir devant nous à la fin
mais on aura
on aura par être dominé le tournoi
alors
on essaye de finir en force la dernière
partie en allant faire un math orageuses
nous exigeons ne fait pas marrer les pas
plié de rire est bon
bahia et prend des 4 je vois plus rien à
tout prendre on va aller attaquer le roi
on va mettre le riche sous pression
j'avais vraiment sous pression ce qui
offre carrément une pièce et on va
pouvoir finir le boulot tranquillement
on sera 41 points je pense ce sera un
poil justin c'est même sûr
ouais mais c'est pour un peu changé ils
ont confessé sa fille pour ce faire
plaisent moins on fait beaucoup 1 sur ce
stream même une belle habitude de
sacrifice qui rentre un peu de se perdre
dans les voies pousser les 5
le roi blanc qui est un peu malin le
cahier qui a fait un grand tour on va re
sacrifier comme tout à l'heure parce que
le roi blanc de paraît un peu aux abois
et puis on prend et du coup maintenant
nada qui si l'histoire que vous êtes
impressionné par tous ces sacrifices
même s'ils sont assis c'est de ma faute
mais bon j'ai joué avec le feu contre
toi boss et s'est passé j'ai pas si j'ai
bel va faire traumatisé aussi après
après mon sacrifice un peu fun d'un
bijou contre 1 800 t il un peu en sueur
pas si facile que ça plongée bête de
battre un adversaire à 800 mhz et c'est
ça le truc c'est que c'est que sa main
sur deux fronts des sacrifices comme ça
partout alors retourné sur notre parti
et qui a valu à f2 partie on va repartir
en même esprit on va prendre là et on va
prendre comme ça on va donner la dame
mais cette fois ci c'est un sacrifice
calculé parce qu'on veut faire tout
reprend des deux échecs au prochain le
fou est cloué et si le roi parents
achats
il y aurait eu du courage de maths et si
par en f2 tous rêvent de donc là on peut
récupérer la dame
sauf qu'on la récupère dans
d'excellentes conditions
puisqu'on se retrouve avec deux pièces
de plus et trois pions ce qui va être
une formalité
ce qui est une formalité est-ce que j'ai
passées à se faire surprendre et non il
va quand même gagné son adversaire pas
de chance à craquer allez on va faire ça
donc le risque est abandonnée on va se
retrouver à combien on se retrouva à 41
points on devrait pas gagner le tournoi
mais on aura fait un bel effort afin
petit 11 sur 11 donc toujours toujours
agréable et voilà on va finir 2e
probablement donc n'hésitez pas à vous
inscrire au tournoi vous avez le lien du
club dans les dents les chat comme ça
vous pouvez facilement le trouver et
donc c'est gratuit de jouer le tournoi
et si vous gagnez toi vous pouvez
demander un abonnement diamant à
tchatche.com falloir écrire pour leur
dire que vous pouvez avoir le
l'abonnement diamants par l'échiquier
plus petit arrêt mais ça dépend ça c'est
le sait le design chaise comme c'est pas
le design vitrine du coup c'est un autre
design mois sur le design chaise comme
j'ai un écran un peu plus grand
l'échiquier un peu plus grand donc ça
dépend on peut on peut changer je leur
dirai à l'occasion et donc je vous
remercie à tous d'avoir suivi le stream
eh ben je vous dis demain soir sur la
chaîne beast rima 21h pour suivre le
pour suivre le live live 2
l'aréna de demain en espérant que ça je
joue un peu mieux ce soir c'était pas
c'était pas folichon folichon
et si vous souhaitez frontières discuter
vous pouvez aller sur le discorde même
si moi j'y serais peut-être pas trop ce
que faut que je me repose un peu en ce
moment merci à tous ciao ciao